and so like pretty early i was you know
um
i was i was met and introduced and so
that and that never did it for me um
jack
nicholson yeah when did you meet jack
because i met jack a few times at the
lakers out of lake that's where i met
him too yes i was in the back room with
jack nicholson
in that back cigar in the cigar room
that was it i was yes yes
that was where it was well i was there
and i was sitting there talking to him
and i go man that's a shame you know
they need shaq to be back in the game
because he was injured or something he's
like yeah well you know it's like if you
know he starts talking about this and
that and everything's fine and we're
having a nice conversation about the
lakers and the season he doesn't miss a
game and and all of a sudden this guy
comes up to him and goes hey jack this
game isn't as good as it gets is it and
he goes
if you'll excuse me and then [ __ ] and i
looked at the guy i go you [ __ ]
i was just talking to nicholson you
[ __ ] it up you [ __ ] up my momma with
nicholson and he goes jesus dude i was
so mad
i know exactly what you were talking
about because for me it was very similar
and in fact there's a in the in the
bowels of staple center by the way he's
referring there is a room chairman's
room there is a room and there is a
cigar room within the room which is if
you're in the room where it happens then
there's another room that you don't even
know that exists for a while
and i was in there
uh i was in there
and and my buddy was with me at the game
and there's also like
very nice bathrooms back then oh yeah in
the in the chair and so my i said i'm
gonna go in and maybe have a little
cigar and my buddy says i'm gonna go to
the bathroom i'll
i'll i'll meet you in there
and it was just me and jack yeah it was
it was just me and jack and my buddy
later tells the story the the door into
that room is a swinging door like it you
know it swings both ways like a you know
at a at a restaurant between the kitchen
and the and the thing my buddy describes
as like pushing the door like pushing
the door like to walk in full speed
seeing that it's me and jack
and slowly backing away and shutting the
door and he gave he gave me that moment
he was like i'm not going to screw this
up i know how he feels about jack i'm
just going to i'm just going to
say i'm just going to back away
uh it was it was
it was largely the same
we discussed the office very briefly
mostly about the lakers i want to say
this was
our the the bulk of our conversation was
about bynum
uh andrew bynum wow center for the
latest in the past yes um that had some
great games and then had some not great
games that i believe that was where the
conversation was focused and
um we beat each other goodbye and then i
you know we sort of
did a hello
several other times after i used to go
quite a bit